hey guys I'm Dan this is Jess it's
Thursday and we're here to get you
caught up in everything that happened
today in gaming special thanks to a fan
of this show who we actually ran into
yesterday well now Elena lunch hi and
thanks for watching for all the rest of
you here today's news Oh also for a fan
for everybody
here's something weird a new street
fighter to cart is being released I
would yes but it's so liable to catch
fire that the product page actually says
you need to have a fire extinguisher
nearby while you're using it
gasp early capcom teamed up with IM
8-bit to create the working SNES
cartridge to celebrate the 30th
anniversary of street fighter that's all
well and good but the ominous warning
associated with the product reads use of
this reproduction game cartridge on the
SNES gaming hardware may cause the SNES
console to overheat or catch fire the
SNES hardware is deemed a vintage
collectible so please exercise extreme
caution when using the product and to
make sure there is fire extinguish 'men
taqwim ania by use of the product is
that the sole risk of the user if that
wasn't worrying enough the warning adds
that neither I am 8-bit nor Capcom but
make the claim that the cartridge is
safety years in a statement I am 8 bits
that it understands the warning may be
extreme but it can't anticipate the
state of the SNES hardware people might
use to play the cartridge so it seems
it's more of a necessary precaution to
cover both consumer and company if the
warning hasn't turned you off you can
grab one of the 5500 limited carts for
100 bucks that will ship in a randomized
color of opaque ryu headband red or
glow-in-the-dark Blanca green let's talk
sonic Sega has announced a release date
for sonic forces as well as details on
the mandatory special edition the
action-adventure game will launch on
November 7 for ps4 Xbox one and PC while
Sonic mania took Sonic back to its 2d
blast process brutes horses is a mixture
of 2d and 3d gameplay where you can play
as classic and modern Sonic as well as a
custom character now I know what you're
all thinking I sure hope I can dress up
my custom speed hook in branded items
from Sega's other popular franchises
well I've got good news if you pick up
the special edition of Sonic faucets
you'll get a custom controller skin and
access to five in-game outfits inspired
by persona 5 Jet Set Radio nights Super
Monkey Ball and poyo poyo
the special edition will set you back 40
bucks and you can pre-order it right now
if you're so inclined
finally in more Sonic news Sonic mania
on PC has been met with criticism over
its use of the de nouveaux DRM system
the anti-tamper DRM requires an always
online internet connection in Sonic
mania which Sega has blamed on a bug and
since
fixed the copy-protection was also never
mentioned in sonic manias steam page
which has now been resolved de nouveaux
is a constant source of aia from pc
gamers as its installation can impact
the performance of a game so while you
can now play sonic mania on pc offline
it still requires the installation of de
novo let us know in the comments below
what you think of this one and what your
ideal copy protection situation is
obviously ideal drm situation is no idea
yeah obviously but it's here to stay
it's gonna be around for a little while
until people find one that works i mean
set of projects it seems like they
cracked it with witcher 3 it was offer a
good product and don't worry I'm on it
well their solution is no drm which is
they run good old games calm which is
basically their whole motto is there is
no DRM personally I mean PC game is a
very particular about what goes on their
system which is why there is so much
controversy around de novo yeah I mean
stuff like you play gets installed and
it you know slows down games makes it
harder to get an actually play stuff
that you've bought especially
single-player games I think the problem
is that there are platforms
even's damn I'm not a particularly big
fan of I was a very late Steam adopter
I get like having all your stuff in one
place is very convenient but I don't
like having to play my gangster a
platformer and then when it goes the
other direction with you know platforms
that aren't as good a team like our
engine or you play especially in their
older editions then it becomes a hurdle
into playing a game and DRM can be like
that too especially when it demands
always online
yeah which in reality for everybody
exactly because that's in Australia we
have very very sporting internet
connections even now even in our office
we have somewhat crappy internet
compared to the rest of the world so it
is hard to really enforce it always
online worldwide I think I think
basically people just want to be able to
play the game stay fly you know when
you're dropping 50 to 100 dollars on a
game you just want to be able to play
that game and not have a bunch of the
added software or platform has to be
fair though some DRM is really funny
like in Batman when are his cape
wouldn't open you just what were you
there that was more of that and I would
like that dear that was good well that
is everything we got for you guys today
do let us know your thoughts on today's
stories down in that comment section and
we'll be back tomorrow with the top 5
stories of the entire week so come by
then if you need to get all caught up
and see you guys then see you guys
you